[Applaudissements]
on était bobo on dirait pas un générique
de jeu mais hyper lagarde n'était pas ça
lui était le seul atout bienvenu e on et
ce soir jusqu'à 19 heures on sent bien
sûr c'est le jeu du big bang ouf c'est
parti
allez hop à ce que tu ta première manche
s'est levé tout le monde
alors martine martin à 25 ans elle vient
du poitou charentes martin attention
bien sûr je vous donnerai c'est une
boutique ou borg
attention c'est facile si vous pensez
que ça va se savoir et ça va cogner
c'est bing si vous pensez que non c'est
pour gagner ces partis premier extrait
ces participants cette musique est folle
je suis mis les niches quoi c'est billy
heinich welch est passé le bidouillage
formidable allez je vous lis c'est une
super artiste paraît super s'était
répété sa série occupe toi tu sais que
deux minutes
qu'est ce qui se passe à faire alors un
mot nage ou pas on dirait pas une baisse
de ramoneur alors elle est où la
cheminée là c'est une nappe en fait
j'utilise aussi en reste et on n'a pas
ça qui est magnifique
non c'est catastrophique j'avoue qu'elle
est moche cédric est trop large et est
papa et au qui la font perdre ces jeux
sont assez bons et on est on est passé
pas j'ai dit c'est pas de jci a dit de
ce que voulait je commence tout de suite
quoi bien sûr on a honte attendait avec
impatience c'est par éclats du gros dos
et j'attends avec impatience son débrief
du prime charles aznavour est
effectivement là justement ne
connaissais pas ça parce que la semaine
vous présentez un prime sur charles
aznavour prime dans lequel vous receviez
notamment des artistes que vous écoutez
tous les jours dans la voiture mireille
mathieu et sylvie vartan
bon je sais que vous écoutez une rupture
tout le temps et assure bien sûr à
l'oreille à un moment que j'ai kiffé
c'est con dans la nouvelle de sylvie
vartan
c'est moi ouais et brel de série de
sylvie vartan est ce qu'on boit elle est
bonne sa mère
allez bonne sur la
[Musique]
et au début au début je ne connaissais
pas la moitié des partants je suis
étonné que ce soit elle mais ça c'est
déjà zhuzhou non pas du tout mais
additionnel ou oui ça c'est donc dans
notre ami un moment que j'ai beaucoup
qu'il fait c'est quand d'un coup mairie
mathieu s'est mise à chanter sans
prévenir personne
tout le monde s'est demandé ce qui se
passait et surtout vous surtout c'est le
retour du zumba et videra
[Musique]
agent après
était monsieur le nabour jezebel c'est
ça ta mais interprété une juin titre de
deux chars la zone shaft
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va durer comme ça une fois les belles
romy mimi insérer ces bourgs tu as vu
quand elle par sa part la casse alors il
ya les nouveaux qui s'est très vite
intégré dans la bande cette année c'est
eric naulleau eric naulleau qui alors
lui qui est habitué plus au débat sur
l'immigration sur la pma il saisit pas
encore tout ce qui se passe il est par
exemple en balance au boss tout à
l'heure dans un gros des bardes et oui
c'est vrai ça même et par exemple eric
et les coudes g parker oscar peterson
il écoute duke ellington alors que c'est
lui il écoute est l'enfoiré et booba ou
encore les poetic lovers
c'est pas la même chose ya pa ta gueule
j'ai dit la vérité c'est la vérité donc
eric le problème c'est que vous n'avez
pas caché qu'à des moments où même eric
zemmour il vous manque
oui même eric zemmour lui ment vous
allez voir vous connaissez la ville à
tous ces si vous connaissez la fête à
neuneu
mais découvrez la tête à mono
elle est où gérald
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
et qui pourtant habitué journée voire
fatale est ce que j'écoutais le plus
[Musique]
fitch est encore au thème de débat tpp
c'est bizarre votre maître se gratter
les parties et rod et voilà c'est à dire
qu'on n'est plus on est moins
attentionné mois d'attenté au bureau
c'est quoi faire caca la porte ouverte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous méritez bien avec nous comme oui
mesdames ou la guerre c'est la limite
[Musique]
abobo
[Applaudissements]
tout du meilleur jeu du bender je te
tuer 3 moratoire sur le vocoder ouais je
pêche
j'adore il ya trois mois que j'ai pas
compris dans une phrase de tournai at
war moratoire bien sûr je connais juste
et ma soeur et moi on s'est passé comme
nous la gare c'est le blé ou lamoulère
on la devine si toi allez vous l'avez
pas du tout la l1 mais les millennials à
72 ans ferme les yeux faire le jeune et
ses potes dit la fille willow l'heure où
la garder mon regard tétouan
[Applaudissements]
ça me veut du mend hers mender ce jeu un
mixeur pour maintenant et c'est moi
c'est quoi si si alors j'ai comme
d'habitude comptabiliser le nombre de
prises de parole et chroniqueur depuis
la dernière fois que je suis venu et il
ya du changement beaucoup de changements
vous allez voir si ces y ait du
changement qui a le plus parlé qui a le
moins parienté pmp seller de n'oubliez
pas de prendre la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
classement 2 n'oubliez pas de prendre la
parole
c'est parti en dernière position cette
semaine avec 19 l'invention retrouve
celle qui un jour en place un mac lesggy
go again m6 qu'il est devenu ce qu'il
s'agit de péter on dorothée et un moment
donné pour le corps et l'esprit c'est
une des choses les plus importantes pour
ce tour d'en avoir on a des positions
retrouve avec 21 une prise de parole
celui qui est meilleur en imitation
quand scoop médias maxime unis
ou du classement et tout donner pour
atteindre la deuxième place
[Musique]
quarante deux interventions pour
isabelle morini-bosc que j'avais avant
il ya totalement inopérant non même
quand il peut rien
[Musique]
et le numéro de cette semaine est
l'homme qui colle si elle n'a depuis
plus de deux ans ça suffit de se frotter
à 50 d'une intervention pour jean louis
schelbert
cinquante et un feuilletage et s'anime
et hdmi sont incroyables vous gêne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment ça me fait plaisir
oui pardon j'interviens mais ta
chronique est formidable de même y avait
une info est ce que vous savez qu'à
orlando était très en colère suite à
l'imitation de maxime quoi or l'italie
dans le dernier termine sur le strabisme
c'est vrai qu'il aime pas non
très en colère ont été réussis mais ça
prouve quand on regarde c'est vraiment
la masse orlando s'il veut venir et
c'est le bienvenu c'est un homme très
drôle à votre post il est sympa et
marrant moi c'est un pote
moi j'aime bien vous aussi ah ouais j'ai
fait c'était l'info de kid mermoud n'ont
pas de même il est par contre comme tu
le connais de sortie en boîte avec moi
tu connais on est tous dans le même
milieu bon alors mobile qui dès midi lé
qui diminue hélios est déjà possible de
[Rires]
réserver ses billets à machin qui a mis
à dia machin chouette et il se dit bien
et est proche mais nous on va on va te
dire quoi langen cadienne mireille
mathieu carlat giyus katia manic et
c'est quelqu'un de vivant
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien de chez nous qu'est-ce qu'il arrive
qu est-ce qui a alors qu'est-ce qu'il va
y avoir du hanul inside en un instant
l'unsa n'envoie savoir ce que vous
pensiez à pendant le prime de charles
aznavour avec fabien lecoeuvre notamment
et vous aurez évidemment vous saurez qui
est le 15e tabac il y en a gagné 14 mais
je pense que cette semaine ça y est
c'est laisser pulsé retrouver dans un
instant richir avec la vue seront la pub
que jean michel maire avait fini en tête
des prises de parole dans l'émission
ouais et si le numéro un c'est donc bien
sûr surtout parce qu'ils passent du
temps à vous faire de la lèche série
c'est vrai donc j'étais obligé vous
préparer un nouveau numéro du fatah
fayot merci
[Musique]
gioria buzzer halte aixois 12h41 du
matin il serait demandé à quelle heure
allait se terminer l'émission
j'imagine quand la tête il fourmille de
projets d'idées on peut pas dormir on
est tout le temps là
savage aux pattes la frite génial
attention c'est très simple son physique
à vous poser le jeu devait dîner avec
des chirurgiens qui m'ont demandé vous
demander si vous aviez fait cet été une
opération de chirurgie esthétique
il ya plein de gens qui demandent je
n'ai jamais rien fait j'ai jamais rien
fait ou alors tu vas y mon et c'était
pour impossible d'atteindre une telle
perfection réside sur france 4 voilà il
m'a frappé pourquoi moi d'ailleurs
voilà est-ce que tu vas y mise là voilà
ça passait hommage à michael jackson
merci vous êtes là parce que dans le
clan plus alors j'ai jamais compris
comment il faut leur nuire oui c'est un
trio tu passes de 12,56 tous le voir
merci moujan mouche
[Musique]
on est honnête c'est notre tombe dessus
la clôture et pc un mélange équitable de
médias de dar k en gros 10 % de médias
90% de ben barka est dense et 90% de
dark eye à la moitié consacrée aux
déguisements c'est un peu la marque de
fabrique de l'émission surtout cette
année j'ai remarqué on va voir les
maires transformation depuis la rentrée
et moi quand j'étais petit j'adorais les
missions vous rappelez de sébastien
c'est bien sûr et bien tu étais un pc un
peu hanouna c'est fou c'est par 6 pts 6
g lol
demain
[Musique]
toujours 2
[Applaudissements]
je vois que basso monde remet cette
farandole le déguisement le meilleur
déguisement restauration et d'isabelle
censé être madame bodin's mais qui m'a
surtout fait pour ça une star de cinéma
c'est vrai qu'on aurait dit si tu y
ailles d'auteuil alors vous savez
quelque fois on a la chance de pénétrer
cyril hanouna
je parle de son cerveau je parle de son
cerveau bien sûr puisque pendant le
prime est évoquée mais regardez c'est
vous qui le regarde et vous la prochaine
fois votre sens du cio et finirent
cependant le pendant le prime monsieur
rémy ont pendant le procès durera louf
remercie aussi donc donc pendant le
prime monsieur aznavour j'entendais ce
que vous pensiez c'est parce que je vous
connais bien et comme d'habitude
j'essaie de traduire au public ce que
vous pensiez vraiment un certain moment
notamment confirmé le club prenait la
parole
j'adore c'est un nouveau hanoune inside
[Musique]
ce soir sylvie nous interprète en direct
la plus belle pour aller danser c'est un
cadeau exceptionnel peu notre histoire
sur ces 8 pour monsieur aznavour
non mais c'est moi qui suis en train de
lancer sylvie vartan là m'ont pris pour
pascal sevran dans la chance aux
chansons quoi fabien vous disiez que
j'aurais à ce nabot aimait beaucoup le
frère de mireille mathieu qui est
boulanger à mouriès est très copain très
très amis on nous parle du boulanger de
charles aznavour le gars moi je les
chiffres qui tombent tous les quarts
d'heure lui avec ses 1 m 61 et son
physique ingrat ce ça marchait pas
ah oui le physique ingrat le gall 10
alors qu'on voit son bide saucissonnés
par sa chemise et qui l'attend en cumul
son gros paquet c'est dégueulasse si
l'ancien rennais mais pas du tout cette
chanson qui faisait un peu music hall un
peu cirque
donc elle a dit à mon temps ne chante
pas sa série finalement c'est comme ça
cazenave au final c'est moi qui présente
je sais qu'il a des cheveux 34400 42
jours vous vous en êtes à 7,16 1430 13
jours déjà
vous faites gaffe parce que c'est près
de votre dernier jour aujourd'hui on
adore
j'adore et donc il est temps
malheureusement de passer au moment fait
pas malheureusement il attend de savoir
qui a gagné le trophée du 15e 1 2 qui
ciblent ces magnifiques puisque c'était
le tabac est évidemment celui que le
plus tacler ses collègues sur le plateau
j'avais quatorze fois que vous gagnez et
mehmeti musique de suspense s'il vous
plaît
un bon mois très franchement je sentis
xavier beaucoup d'amour cette semaine
est saturé que j'avais beaucoup d'amour
a surtout le désir des jours vous étiez
pas là c'était sont les chroniqueurs est
ce qu'à votre avis vous avez gardé de le
trophée d'or valait et bien ce soir le
15e trophée du fair baba est attribué à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors pas trouvé le mât trouble et une
après vous adore si toi aussi et que
j'ai aussi ce côté artiste showman on le
voit sur scène puisque j'avais le côté
artiste au chômage françois viot la
question est simple trop vieux doit-il
se marient tous quitté fait un trop gros
sacrifices en revanche pourquoi taper un
emploi du temps aménagé à partir du
jeudi soir tu l'a rejointe et une heure
de train bah oui tu dis jusqu'au lundi
matin avec ma bulle je peux t'en levée
jeudi soir une fois par mois
ah non plus indispensable c'est bon quoi
particularité physique chez les pieds
plats malheureusement cette année et que
tu
un monde que vous retournez sur nrj 12
[Applaudissements]